this once feared warlord during
liberia's decade-long civil war says
he's now fighting a drug epidemic he's
my pops says this man i would kill for
him
in these ghettos in the capital monrovia
the children who once fought for him
have now grown into gang members and
drug addicts
they call him general but naked because
he fought without clothes alongside
children hooked on drugs he provided
before going into battle bloody says he
and his army of child soldiers ate the
hearts of children they'd captured
i'm looking for g-money yeah
money promised me
that you would give me
20 children under the age of 15.
for what purpose asks this man the enemy
is attacking the most brilliant children
that's why you see this that's one worry
the nation is going to be strangulated
if we don't rescue these guys
the enemy he refers to are drug lords in
monrovia we're told to leave and that
gangs are after us
the un says liberia is among several
west african countries used as transit
hubs for cocaine and heroin coming from
latin america and asian countries to
european markets the next day we meet
blai at his home
in his backyard are barracks for the
teenagers he's picked off the streets
they say nigerian gang members are
distributing drugs in the ghettos
hooking children on heroin or
pharmaceuticals like the painkiller
trauma doll i want to become a lawmaker
because no one will talk for us in the
house of representatives we are
vulnerable on the streets smoking drugs
i want to become a lawmaker to protect
my friends
play has admitted to the country's truth
and reconciliation commission that he's
responsible for the killings of more
than 20 000 people during the civil war
now he says he's these children's
protector
the work that the former warlord joshua
has done with street children has
attracted public sympathy and has
protected him in effect from public
prosecution despite the recommendations
made by the truth and reconciliation
commission
blaise says protecting children is a way
for him to repent for his past crimes i
think what i did were wrong and there is
no excuse for it and me and others who
did this should pay for it but as i'm
waiting for justice i want to be giving
back
for this former warlord liberia has
become the front line of a drug war it
cannot afford to lose
he says it's a battle he will fight out
of responsibility and guilt for his past
crimes and for his country
statements that few here are in a
position to challenge
nicholas hawk al-jazeera monrovia